I'm going to name a sport you have to
tell me the greatest of all time mhm
sounds good yeah basketball LeBron
James soccer Messi baseball Barry
Bonds what did he say Okay American
football Tom Brady I guess okay yeah
good one tennis jokovic was it always
jokovic for you you thought maybe no it
was after the um Australian Open thing
that he became the greatest for me was
it Nadal before Federal
probably fed but I always identified
more with the way than a doll place
Golf
Tiger Fair poker dog Brunson that's a
unique one
chess Gary Kasparov are you allowed to
say
yourself I don't know if I'm allowed but
Gary is the best while Time stuff CH
boxing am on Hamilton